lá tudo bem eu tenho um roteiro aqui pra
fazer com vocês mas antes queria dividir
com vocês uma experiência que acabei de
ter aquino no bastidor o próximo
palestrante
quando eu entrei aqui ele está esperando
no bastidor lucas e assim que entrei na
sala que ficou amarrado enfim para me
preparar
nunca se olhou pra mim e falou assim eu
conheço você em algum lugar e aí eu não
sabia exatamente que um pouco sem graça
e bom pensa ir acabou sendo fala e até
descobrir que ele foi meu aluno dez anos
atrás um pouco mais de dez anos atrás
é ele ficou super feliz fez uma
homenagem poxa mudou minha vida foi
muito legal passar por aquela escola
na verdade não foi meu aluno directo era
vice diretor da escola onde ele estudou
então pouco acionado porque o retorno é
a hora que a gente encontra ou passa por
essa situação e foi bastante
interessante de fato
então eu vou começar fazendo a mesma
coisa invertido homenagear um professor
meu é um dia mais de 20 anos atrás da
faculdade é fazer ficar na história e
muito tempo e eu estava numa aula e e
era uma aula do professor que eu mais
gostava
possivelmente professora o melhor
professor que tive na vida um professor
de história chamar julho pimentel e ele
chegou com um texto
aí falou nós vamos curtir uma coisa um
pouco diferente hoje eu queria vir aqui
com vocês e o texto falava sobre como a
cidade
as intervenções urbanísticas o traçado
da cidade o desenho as avenidas as ruas
os prédios arquitetura daquela cidade
poderiam revelar a elementos
fundamentais para que nós estudantes de
história pudéssemos identificar aquela
sociedade e ele começou a mostrar o
texto como falar disso e eu me
interessei demais não trabalho com isso
mas é até hoje a parte que eu tenho do
molde moro é é contato ou que é mais
querida minha
no estudo da história o estudo muito
história do urbanismo mesmo que não
trate isso profissionalmente
então é uma boa oportunidade para falar
de algo que faz parte da minha formação
intelectual enfim mas que não é o meu
trabalho
na verdade o meu hobby e aí lendo ali o
trecho que o texto que o professor julho
é apresentou é eu acabei descobrindo que
de fato o modo como as cidades eram
organizadas poderiam revelar não só a
história daquela sociedade mas
fundamentalmente foi a parte que mais
gostei
é como a cidade ajudava a criar regras
de convivência entre as pessoas que a
partir dali portanto é faziam a essa
relação entre elas a partir da mediação
que essas regras exercem e essas regras
eram bastante influenciadas pela cidade
pelo traçado da cidade pela arquitetura
em pela questão urbanística o exemplo no
caso do professor julho era a viena
capital da áustria que é até hoje
considerado uma das cidades mais
importantes é uma das melhores cidades
do mundo senão a melhor ea áustria de
fato o viena de fato passou por uma
reforma urbanística é no final do século
19 esse é o tema do trecho estava lendo
com o professor é que transformou a
cidade uma das cidades mais modernas do
mundo
em resumo foi mais ou menos o seguinte
que aconteceu e vieram ele se uma parte
antiga da cidade que era bastante
tradicional e que ficava ali é os
prédios ou as representações que estavam
no centro da cidade é que eram
referentes a monarquia do império austro
húngaro que era algo muito tradicional
naquela região família dos habsburgo
toda a tradição monárquica da áustria e
aquela região
de alguma maneira foi cercada por uma
intervenção urbanística que foi feito na
cidade é por uma rua que eles chamam de
rua do anel porque ela tem de fato um
formato circular que cerca esse centro
da cidade e que de alguma maneira
integra portanto esse centro mais
tradicional
as regiões de fora desse círculo que são
as regiões mais novas que davam conta
dos bairros operários enfim os bairros
mais recentes da cidade
essa relação entre eles de proteção
entendem isso quer dizer
o centro da cidade era de alguma maneira
protegido por uma rua em forma de
círculo um anel que então protegia esse
centro e ao mesmo tempo garantia a
relação dessa parte mais tradicional da
cidade com as partes de fora do círculo
que eram as partes mas novas da cidade e
que isso garantiu portanto algum tipo de
entendimento e de relacionamento entre
aqueles moradores do centro a nobreza é
austríaca e os moradores das partes mais
novas que estão fora do círculo
não é à toa que nessa rua e lada nesse
círculo que tem lá em viena estão todos
os elementos que compõem
a cidade moderna de viena o teatro o
parlamento os parques a biblioteca
universidade estão todas nessa rua na
balada que cercam o centro da cidade
é isso representava não só uma
modernização da cidade vê na mas
representava no plano urbanístico uma
espécie de acompanhamento de todo o
clima de é efervescência cultural entre
tóquio e intelectual que viana vivia
naquele momento então é a mesma época
por exemplo que vai surgir a pintura do
gustavo clientes que é bastante famoso e
representa a arte dessa região no final
do século 19 começou com o 20 é aí que
vai nascer o que vai crescer o que vai
aprender os seus primeiros passos na
ciência o floyd
a psicanálise de freud nasce também
dessa cidade moderna que viena se
transformou no final do século 19
é como se viena se candidatar se a ser
uma espécie de contraponto de
modernidade à paris pares representando
a belle époque europeia e viena sendo
uma espécie de contraponto germânico a
essa modernidade que paris apresentava
bom
olhando pra isso alguns anos depois já
no mestrado em economia eu aprendi
alguma coisa que nos meus alunos
normalmente escutam é que eu mesmo falo
para eles que é a economia o
desenvolvimento econômico depende é
claro que terra de capital de tecnologia
mas também depende de instituições e as
instituições são as regras que fazem a
mediação entre os agentes os indivíduos
as empresas dos representantes do
governo e assim por diante
e aí eu tentei associar as duas coisas
será possível então que a cidade como
cria ambientes favoráveis a determinados
tipos de relacionamento entre os agentes
entre os indivíduos entre os cidadãos
possa ser considerada então uma
instituição e essas instituições a
depender de como elas impacto no
desenvolvimento econômico
nós teremos maior ou menor
desenvolvimento e as palavras as cidades
impacto no nosso desenvolvimento
econômico o modo como nós desenhamos as
cidades
o modo como nós fazemos intervenções
urbanísticas nessas cidades é impacto na
maneira que nós produzimos o nosso
desenvolvimento econômico
essa questão institucional e chama muita
atenção porque ela se diz
em duas partes ou ela se subdivide em
mais dois itens
o primeiro item essa sim essas
instituições elas podem ser formais ou
informais
então pode ser formais na hora que elas
são escritas na hora que elas são
representadas pelas regras formais pela
constituição e pelas leis por aqueles
que representam as regras formais
enfim é congresso judiciário políticas
públicas todas elas são representantes
das regras formais portanto das
instituições formais
agora tem uma parte que é informal que
são instituições informais e que o que
cabe aí são as regras de costume são as
regras de convivência são as regras que
nós construímos ao longo do tempo e que
não são necessariamente escritas mas que
fazem repito a mediação entre os
indivíduos entre os indivíduos e as
empresas entre as empresas e os
representantes do governo por exemplo
essas regras institucionais ou essas
instituições informais também subdividem
em outros dois entre outras duas
categorias em outras duas categorias
a primeira delas é instituições que são
mais inclusivas instituições que são
menos inclusivas
eu tentando juntar essas coisas se as
cidades produzem instituições porque
criam regras de mediação entre os
agentes entre os indivíduos e portanto
elas podem ser entendidas como
representantes dessas instituições e se
as instituições são importantes para o
nosso desenvolvimento econômico então as
cidades são importantes para o nosso
desenvolvimento econômico
mais do que isso se as instituições
podem ser formais ou informais e
principalmente mais inclusivas ou menos
inclusivas cidades mais inclusivas ajuda
no desenvolvimento econômico de longo
prazo
ok então esse é um raciocínio para
tentar juntar aquilo que me é
característica da profissão eu sou
historiador econômico mas aquilo que
também é característica do hobby que eu
tenho que estudar a história do
urbanismo e essas duas combinações me
fez pensar então na minha cidade
então eu vou olhar pra minha cidade e
vou tentar perceber se ela ao longo do
tempo é inclusiva o suficiente ou ela
tem alguns momentos de mais inclusão ou
se ela criou instituições mais
inclusivas que possam de alguma maneira
têm impactado no desenvolvimento
econômico da minha cidade sempre
pergunta as pessoas sempre
dou uma dica às pessoas que elas olhem
para as idades delas
olhe para sua cidade veja se a sua
cidade e inclusive veja se a sua cidade
teve algum momento que ela pode ser
considerado então mais inclusiva
de modo que você possa considerar essa
institucionalidade urbana certo comuns e
impactante no desenvolvimento econômico
eu fui na minha cidade o vencedor de são
paulo e aí fiz da história porque eu sou
historiador então feito da história de
são paulo ea história de são paulo e
revelou algumas passagens muito
interessantes que eu poderia de alguma
maneira aproximar com esse problema que
eu levantei sobre as instituições
urbanas sobre a inclusividade e sobre
desenvolvimento econômico e chama a
atenção duas coisas fred tem várias mas
duas passagens da história de são paulo
o urbanista na história urbana de são
paulo e chamar a atenção
uma delas é é um é uma ocupação da
cidade de são paulo que segue o eixo
leste oeste e oeste do rio tietê
ok o eixo leste oeste é ocupação das
fábricas ea partir disso da estrutura de
transporte porque na fábrica você
precisa fez boa estrutura de transporte
para poder levar matéria prima para
fabricar tirar o produto já transformado
e evidentemente levar os operários dessa
fábrica que tiraram os operários dessa
fábrica para que eles possam ir pra casa
então há um eixo leste-oeste que segue o
rio tietê que vai ser ocupado por esse
processo de industrialização no momento
fundamental da história de são paulo que
é quando o dinheiro o recurso capital
gerado pela produção e venda de café no
interior de são paulo começa a
transbordar de tal modo que vai alcançar
a capital o espaço mais urbanizado
então esse dinheiro do café servir de
alguma maneira como anteparo para esse
desenvolvimento industrial no eixo leste
oeste da cidade de são paulo
no ano são clubística mas nós temos dois
símbolos e clubes importantes não só do
brasil mas de são paulo que simbolizam
de novo né que simbolizam isso que eu
queria dizer na ponta leste o
corinthians na ponta oeste o palmeiras
ok não é à toa que eles são rivais
porque eles formam exatamente as duas
pontas desse eixo que foi a ocupação no
começo do século 20 final de 1910 a
cidade de são paulo um pouco
mais moderna por conta do dinheiro do
café por conta do crescimento que o café
permitiu então esse é o primeiro eixo o
que têm entre eles
entre eles têm a moka ok bairro de
italianos entre eles têm a passagem do
fundo do centro da cidade que é ali a
campos elíseos
ok entre eles tenha barra funda quando
chega na barra funda está chegando perto
portanto o palmeiras é ali tem um
problema sério que é o alagamento e
alaga demais portanto que está muito
perto do rio tietê e tem uma dificuldade
ali é do escoamento da água como alagava
muitas pessoas que enriqueceram um
pouquinho nessa região
elas têm de um a sair de lá para fugir
dessa região do alagamento que causava
transtorno a eles
eles vão subindo porque vão saindo de
perto do rio e vão subir em direção à
região mais alta da cidade para que eles
não sejam pegos não sejam comprometidos
aí por conta dos alagamentos conforme
eles vão subindo a cidade
na cabeça deles vai ficando mais limpa
por isso que entra barra funda ea parte
alta da cidade tem um bairro chamado e
genô polis
a cidade fica higiênica e nesse sentido
quando eles iam subindo pra avenida
paulista é vai mostrando portanto a
capacidade que essas pessoas que estavam
lá embaixo na região do rio
certo começam a subir a encontrar no
meio da avenida paulista ou em direção à
avenida paulista com as pessoas que lá
viviam que em geral as pessoas donas das
fábricas e donos das fazendas de café
não matou o prédio da federação da
indústria do estado de são paulo fica no
centro da avenida paulista que é
exatamente isso que ele simboliza a
ocupação dessa região
isso significa dizer que depois de tanto
tempo a gente olha pra ao lado pra
avenida paulista ao lado da fiesp tem o
colégio tradicional dos imigrantes
italianos
o dante alighieri que é exatamente o
mesmo grupo de imigrantes que
trabalhavam nas fábricas lá embaixo
lá perto da idéia do estádio palmeiras
que era ocupação dos italianos na zona
oeste de são paulo
portanto há uma composição da cidade que
vai criando ambientes de encontro entre
essas pessoas por conta da maneira que a
cidade cresceu para poder finalizar aqui
pra não tomar muito tempo de vocês têm
um outro eixo importante e esse outro
eixo importante não é o leste oeste
mas é o norte sul que vem da serra da
cantareira desce em direção ao rio
pinheiros
ea região das represas no centro da
cidade
é esse eixo norte-sul ele se divide em
forma de y à direita na região do
anhangabaú
você vai pra avenida nove de julho e vai
até o rio pinheiros à esquerda você pega
23 de maio em direção ao aeroporto de
congonhas ea interlagos na sequência e
se acha que a direita no fundo os dois
são ocupados de maneiras muito próximas
mas eu queria destacar esse eixo da
direita da avenida nove de julho que vai
até o rio pinheiros
quem faz esse eixo da zona norte é ocupa
esse lixo da zona norte em direção à
zona sul
não são os imigrantes italianos como o
eixo leste oeste mas os imigrantes
alemães e essa imigração alemã acabou
produzindo alguns bairros da cidade de
são paulo como brooklin como o ema como
campo belo mas fundamentalmente produziu
um clube que fica exatamente quando a
avenida 9 de julho vai encontrar com o
rio pinheiros chama clube pinheiros que
chamava germânia e que deixou de ser
chamado de germânia na segunda guerra
mundial porque nós declaramos guerra à
alemanha portanto foi proibido que
tivesse qualquer eheheheh representação
aí dessa cultura germânica o alemão
italiana por conta da guerra é esse
clube pinheiros portanto simboliza o
outro eixo norte sul que também vai ser
ocupado pelos migrantes percebo se há um
eixo leste oeste e há um eixo norte-sul
e algum ponto eles se encontram
ok e é aí que tá portanto simbolicamente
a capacidade que nós tivemos na
trajetória de são paulo de criar uma
cidade que em determinados momentos não
obstante tem uma série de problemas
ainda persistentes mas em determinados
momentos conseguiram criar uma situação
de maior inclusive dade desses que eram
os imigrantes que estavam ocupando esses
eixos de desenvolvimento da cidade
cidades mais inclusivas instituições
mais inclusivas maior desenvolvimento
econômico
o resto da história vocês conhecem muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]